[Music]
do any of you guys have dogs at home i
have two i used to there's three of them
they died what
geez man
all at the same time no one of them had
a seizure other one were old wow all
right man
well you know when dogs go crazy when
they get zoomies and they start running
around yeah
you put them out in the yard yeah and
they just go
yeah well um a lady was watching her dog
do that and then the dog got really
excited and and like jumped at her
crashed into her and here she is on life
support
whoa
she [ __ ] cracked her head or
something or from what
from a dog zooming into her how fast
it was a bull terrier okay so he's hefty
he's a hefty guy it's a hefty yeah it's
a big boy i
it was running out at her and she didn't
think anything of it so she bent down
and then the dog headbutted her in the
jaw oh knocked her out
uh it didn't even knock her out here's
the thing she didn't even think anything
of it what little did she know like the
next day she kind of like a stiff neck
she couldn't really swallow what the
[ __ ] going on
turns out she goes to the hospital they
check and they're like oh maybe you have
an infection
going on in here
but actually she got these cracks in her
molars oh my god which developed an
abscess
which infected and caused this whole
thing to swell up and then they were
afraid she wouldn't be able to breathe
so they had to put her in life support
while they drained the infection out
whoa
that's crazy
within one day um within a couple days a
few days yeah a few days because they
were they were like
if her uh passages shut that's why the
guys at the yulin dog fest was like
that's why i eat them man
this is their this is their go-to story
you guys want to love them as pets you
want to be on live support or what
that's why you eat up
don't ask questions that's how you eat
them man
can you believe that you only eat
dangerous things
so she's okay now like she ended up
surviving everything but it's just off
of that dude it's crazy how like well we
hear stories of people taking out trash
and then that [ __ ] trash bag was
leaking trash juice and they got
something infected and now they got
[ __ ] gang green or some [ __ ] and they
got a dang green they gotta [ __ ] cut
their legs off or something you know
what happened to the the guy who runs
the midnight mission in downtown uh he
got some like bum [ __ ] on his leg and
then he had to cut it off oh my god bump
shit's radioactive
bump [ __ ] probably got like
colvid 20 20. i mean literally like bum
like fecal matter yeah oh i thought you
meant like
in a general like a bum touched him and
he got gangrene i was like i believe
that
just a touch of bum yeah
damn bugs are crazy like uh where jill's
bomb lives
there's like this alleyway right next to
the house
man
the other day i went there there was a
[ __ ] boat there
a ball
i was like okay i call him jesus because
there's this guy that looks like jesus
hey jesus is gonna sell the seven seas
i'm like what the [ __ ] how did they get
a boat there i don't know but they
dragged the [ __ ] boat into their pile
of scraps was it a nice boat
i liked it
it's like you see
he's got expensive tapes like metal
metal straps and [ __ ] and then a [ __ ]
boat on a hitch too like it's ready to
be someone dragged it on like a hitch or
yeah
you should you should you should went to
the boat and said jesus hey how much is
this dude
that guy's crazy i don't want to talk to
that's just so great i just imagined you
starting a stand-up thing and going bam
bubs is crazy
i'll never smell some bump [ __ ] before
then right away and silver like boo
they're like you and me
i was walking down the alleyway of the
house and then uh i was like i saw a
pile of [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god it smells
and then i walked like two more steps
and then you smell pee and then i walked
around and there was [ __ ] throw up
like the whole story was right there
the holy trinity the trail of tears yeah
like [ __ ] these guys can i show you
guys a video of a bum outside my
freaking studio yeah
i like this recent yes
it's like literally from this week
i might have a video of the [ __ ] boat
too yeah
this guy was taking a [ __ ] on the other
side of one of my uh roller doors
[Laughter]
oh
yeah
[Music]
you just walked up and recorded them
i like there's nothing i can do i like
how you commented after you hit record
record ah man
so then i get the uh the cop cause like
i'm right next to the district police
office so i'm like hey guys some dude's
trying to take a [ __ ] can you like get
him out of here he's not trying he's
actively [ __ ] him yeah so by the
time we by the time we walked back he'd
already like shat like he had a sweater
under his ass and he was like [ __ ]
in it so it looked like a [ __ ] one of
those uh
it looked like a breakfast claw stacked
up and then he was [ __ ] the sweater
yeah he [ __ ] on his own sweater like a
like a hammock did he leave it there
yeah he made like a so then he's sitting
in it and then the cops like hey bud can
you get out of here there's nothing the
cop can do yeah because obviously he
doesn't want to touch him and then plus
like
they're kind of they got their hands
tied when they're dealing with homeless
people so he's like hey can you get out
of here and then the guy takes his
sweater that he just [ __ ] in
and he picks it up and he like david
goliath swung it like a sling into the
street
and all the cars in front of him
bro
see look this is the [ __ ] there's a
[ __ ] boat right there
[Laughter]
why is there
jesus cleaning up the [ __ ] fake mess
but he's just swirling the mess around
that's a really nice boat how did that
boat get there it's a sweet ass boat
that's a pretty cool boat right it's a
sweet boat
i mean someone had to have a car or do
you think they pushed the trailer they
should sell it even on main street
there's a guy living in a school bus
yeah i passed that bus all the time on
the way to barbell really honestly you
guys need to move
i i don't know how else to tell you guys
i don't i don't want to be rude but you
guys need to move man like there's
there's nicer places out there like in
orange county you know
these problems just feels bad for you
guys like in orange county
it's so powerful that they moved all the
homeless to one city which city santa
ana oh oh really and it's really bad
it's really bad but they they move them
to city hall
so city hall if you have to go do any
county business city hall it just smells
like poop and pee the whole all all over
city hall
but like they were on the freeway like
bordering the freeway they removed them
they were going to send them to irvine
irvine of course yeah right yeah and
then how do they how do they get them to
move
i don't know that's insane okay in l.a
right now they're like near the arts
district i think right in l.a all of the
above district so literally everywhere
yeah everywhere when i was when i was in
college in like the uh mid-90s
um they were on spring street
oh and then when they caucasianized i
mean sorry gentrified the area they move
them block by block and then they used
to be all the way by spring they're all
all in spring so back then when i lived
in downtown l.a
at 6 p.m no one was no one wasn't going
on the street yeah
there's nowhere to go because there was
a lot of homeless
like right there on spring street
but then yeah once they started
building they just moved them block by
block until
my guess is if they move them far enough
where they can still develop and to
where no one's complaining
so it's like skid row area yeah but now
it's back they're just back everywhere
everywhere yeah
yeah it was because we have a bunch of
imported homeless people
yeah i heard a lot of people just come
to la yeah yeah i would you know i
remember when i was a little kid and i
was like if i was homeless
i don't want to stay here i'll
scrounge up enough money and go to
hawaii yeah that's what a lot of people
do i think about that as well the thing
that just makes it like it's hard for me
to get to wrap my head around it's like
there's people with jobs
and like decent living that are barely
hanging on here and they can't even
bounce back like if i started from
homeless and i was and i picked la
that's the hardest mode you're asking
it's the hardest place to bounce back
from that is the hardest like you have
everything against you but the weather's
not gonna kill you that's the best not
like new york i think yeah like other
states will [ __ ] kill you because
it's like yo that giant blizzards went
through new york or whatever they had to
like move into the subway because it's
like yeah that's what doesn't make sense
to me about the political programs that
they put in place for them it's like
really you're gonna help them
get to what point exactly yeah because
all of it's impossible and that's if
they want help right that's right if
they want a lot of them don't they like
the freedom yeah but it's like dude like
there's no point that you're like all
right you're good to go on your own like
absolutely not it's like how could you
last like economically in la there's no
way because you can't do low income
housing they have rent control but you
can't do low income housing in la
because no one's going to sell their
land to like low income housing or like
you know offer their land out oh yeah
hey yeah put up a 50 000 condo here and
all the low income housing is like a 10
15 year wait yeah you know so it's like
it's almost damn near possible we knew a
guy that was running for um
um
this campaign which is to clean up the
homeless situation it's like everybody's
like thing now yeah but he was uh he's
also like an entertainment lawyer and
all that he started digging into like
why the homeless problem we spend
billions of dollars trying to fix it it
just gets worse where is it going and he
found out that there's a huge network of
corruption
in the city there's so many people that
benefit from keeping homeless homeless
that he was like oh this is the problem
and then so obviously he's going to get
a lot of pushback he didn't win we
actually funded a part of his campaign
we wanted him to win because i'm like
dude this is my city like i was born and
raised here i want this [ __ ] to be
cleaned up like i remember when i was a
kid going to church like near downtown
l.a on the way there there used to be
just like a stereotypical homeless scene
with the with the burning trash can and
like cars on just [ __ ] bricks and
[ __ ] and i was like damn that's nuts but
then it doesn't have to be that way but
it's just been that way and it's because
the city itself benefits from homeless
you know so like yeah he didn't win
because everybody's much more powerful
yeah because whenever whenever they go
we're going to tackle this homeless
problem we're going to build this
facility all the budget goes to soft
costs and it's like wait you guys spent
60 million on consultants before even
breaking ground breaking all that bread
with their friends yeah yeah like what
the [ __ ] did you guys do to this money
and i think they have their homeless
have their own like kind of crime
syndicate too where they you know when
they collect money and they pull it up
you know and they have their own
underworld thing because i don't think i
saw the documentary matrix they they
have that whole um
it's called zion right yeah yeah they
have their own little syndicate no one's
i think kanye is one of their
by the way it's going there like jesus
valenciaga came out with some homeless
clothes too it's a whole fast that's
homeless appropriation yeah honestly
you